welcome to the thankful Thursday I
believe it's important to thank the
people in your life who pilot an impact
with helped you with your company
because you can't do this alone and it's
nice to every now and then say thank you
so today i want to thank you guys my
YouTube subscribers I recently passed
25,000 subscribers and it's a nice
milestone for me one year ago I had six
thousand subscribers now I'm at 25,000
that's a you know four times increase
and I'm growing at ten percent plus
every single month and it's it's awesome
it's great to see the growth you guys
mean so much to me and my daily routine
and keeping me motivated and excited and
answering your questions and makes me
feel good it makes me feel awesome and
YouTube's become such a big part of my
life and in great part because of you
guys my subscribers so I want do
something special what I was thinking
was doing was a special hang out with me
where you've had me for an hour it'd be
a live session you can ask me any
question you want about your business or
whatever i guess and i would answer it
for you and be fun way to kind of
interact with each other i'm thinking
about a thursday afternoon probably
three o'clock four o'clock eastern
somewhere around there so if you guys
like that idea you want to do that
personal hang out with me leave a
comment below since i have 25,000
subscribers if i get 25 or more comments
will make it happen okay so leave a
company law let me know what you think
and for those of you watching you know
take some time today just to thank
somebody it could be a friend family
member employee somebody you've told
your idea to and they give you energy
and they believe in you take time just
to say thank you it'll make them feel
great it'll make you feel great they'll
spread some good karma in the world and
they'll continue to help your business
grow believe thank you guys so much for
watching if you like to chat me I see
more click on the subscribe button don't
forget to leave that comment and I'll
see you soon
hi I'm Tori flung from time an internal
chef com-mn colitis NewsCenter ethic
subscribe
you